Well,
it's a difficult challenge to figure out
now what to do with this information
from the mind sciences.
My prediction is that legal theory is
going to be in legal.
Cirrus in the law are going to be
focused on this and struggling with this
and entangled in these difficult
questions going forward for,
for who knows how long.
One of the,
um,
one of the things to be aware of is that
in every area of law there exist a place
where the law and legal decision makers
recognize the power of situation.
And when they do the law changes the
outcome of the law changes.
So I teach tort law for example,
and we are,
uh,
we are in tort law,
very prone to say that people assumed
the risk that they made choices and
therefore they should bear the
consequences.
Um,
and we are also inclined not to allow
there to be liability,
um,
uh,
where we think the parties could have
contract.
So we say,
look,
if if you use someone else's stuff and
you could have gained consent and you
didn't,
you're going to have to pay.
We may have to put you in jail.
We call this sort of property rule
protection.
Well,
there are times when we say that doesn't
apply,
that the situation actually played a
role that doesn't typically play a role.
And so now we're going to adjust the
law.
I'm an example,
a famous example in tort law is,
um,
is the case of,
uh,
of,
a family out on a,
on a boat,
on a lake.
In a sudden storm comes up and now this
family is stuck in the middle of the
like and they need to get somewhere for
safety.
They see a doc and they approached the
dock,
they tried to get on it and they're
pushed off right.
And now as a consequence of the person
on the dock pushing them off something
that,
that the person is generally entitled to
do because of it's their property.
So property rule protection,
the boat slams against the shore,
it's damaged and some of the people are
injured.
So that's at least a variation of a,
of an actual,
of an actual case.
A tort law,
uh,
recognizes that in those situations
where a storm comes up and people are
looking to protect their lives,
that it's not exactly their disposition
that's leading them.
It's more their situation to our law
says then that you're permitted to use
someone else's doc.
Um,
and that if they do try to push you off,
they're going to have to compensate you
for the consequences.
So there's an example of where the law
is,
is adjusted to take situation into
account.
I could take you through every of law.
I won't,
uh,
in part because I don't know them all.
But if I did,
I would take you through all of them and
show you that in every area of law there
is a place where situation comes in.
And so the law has already struggled
with this.
It's just particulate picked a
particular sort of dividing line.
Um,
so in contract law we say if someone
puts a gun to your head and says you're
your money or your life and you give
your wallet,
that's not an enforceable contract.
He wasn't your disposition that led you
to do it.
It was your situation.
And so we changed the law to reflect it.
I think one a general way in which the
law is going to have to deal with this.
It's going to have to slide a slide.
The sort of the dividing point between
wind situation matters and when
disposition matters.
Um,
and that's going to be difficult because
there is some simplicity and um,
um,
and there's something affirming about
the idea that if something bad has
happened to someone,
it's because they chose it.
So there will be resistance to this.
But I think that the mind sciences are
going to appeal to those who are
committed to kind of a truth,
uh,
to,
um,
to expand those circumstances in which
we take s situation seriously.
Now,
if you do that and you begin thinking
about problems like crime,
um,
this doesn't mean that you're suddenly
saying,
well,
because criminal behavior was
situationally cause we should set all
the criminals free.
It's actually much more complicated than
that,
but it,
but its implications,
um,
can be quite concrete.
So one thing it might do is it might
suggest to you that if criminals behaved
a certain way,
it's not a solution to changing that
behavior simply to say that those people
should be put behind bars because if
they are indeed moved by situation,
and we might look at a number of
situational factors,
but some of the classics that already
come to mind are things like poverty and
hunger that might lead people to behave
in criminal ways that we're not going to
change that behavior if we attribute
what they did simply to their
dispositions and miss the fact that they
were operating in an environment which
would lead many people,
including perhaps ourselves to behave
the same way.
So it's focus on behavior,
uh,
kind of an instrumentalist view of law.
Asking how can we change what people do
that might lead us to change how we
respond to criminal behavior to be sure
we may put people behind bars,
but behind bars we may be less likely to
say they are of a certain character and
therefore we just make them do their
time.
There's nothing we can do.
Maybe we can change their situation
behind bars and maybe we can change the
situation of people who are not behind
bars to lead,
uh,
to lead others,
to engage in less of that kind of
conduct.
A commitment to trying to do something
about the actual problem,
I think entails a commitment to shedding
the simple just model.
And one more concrete thing I would add
and that is that
our institutions themselves are,
are sort of sources of,
of situational influence.
And we have for the most part,
been blind to those situational
influences and have assume that the way
people have operated as a function of
their disposition and not their
institutions in part for that reason,
I think we don't pay close attention to
the way in which there exists a
competition over our institutions.
A competition that changes our
institutions and in turn changes us.
And this might be everything from our
government congress,
our judiciary,
whether whether judges,
state judges,
for example or elected may have real
implications for the outcomes of the
decisions and what the nature of those
elections are.
Whether money from large corporations or
other groups can influence those
institutions is something,
again,
we've been not inclined to ask very
carefully in part because of our faulty
view of the human animal.
So I would say there are many concrete
ways in which,
um,
I sort of a more situationist,
perspective might change the law.
The details of it though,
I think require first accepting,
uh,
kind of the nature of the problem.
And second,
a,
I'm more general,
a attempt on the part of many of our
best and brightest legal scholars and
young law students and indeed our judges
to help sort out exactly what this
means.